ganz besonders wichtig ist natürlich die
balance zwischen wirtschaft und
gesundheit und genau darüber möchten wir
jetzt sprechen mit einem der führenden
ökonomen dieses landes michael hüther
vom iw köln und einem haus und landarzt
und zwar doktor thomas aßmann guten
abend an sie beide danke dass sie hier
mit uns in der sendung sind eher wir
sprechen heute über die lockerungen die
morgen vielleicht verkündet werden und
dann möchte ich direkt sie herr doktor
assmann fragen wenn es jetzt zu
lockerungen kommt was denken sie sollte
man daher auf die mediziner hören oder
auf die wirtschaft also ich glaube wir
müssen uns da mal ehrlich mal und zwar
ist es so aussah als arzt würde ich
natürlich sagen um den virus zu
eliminieren oder die pandemie fertig zu
machen
das sollten wir das bis ende des jahres
machen so dann wäre unsere wirtschaft im
ich muss zum beispiel auch jeden monat
etwa 30.000 euro an löhnen zahlen ja und
wir haben etwa 20 prozent weniger
patienten beiden verängstigt sind nach
praxis zu kommen
ich würde das wirtschaftlich auch nicht
mehr lange zeit waren wir müssen jetzt
mal ehrlich machen und überlegen was ist
das sinnvollste einmal für die
gesundheit und für die wirtschaft wir
werden keinen idealen standpunkt hin wo
wir alles zusammenbringen
aber wir müssen gucken dass wir
maximalen schutz der bevölkerung haben
und einen minimalen schaden für die
wirtschaft das so genannte minimale das
weiß der mann wahrscheinlich noch besser
aber wir müssen aber lachen und immer
wieder
da gibt es auch eine diskussion hier im
land schon länger dass virologen
momentan am meisten bestimmen wie sehen
sie das stimmt das und wenn ja ist das
ein fehler unserer regierung wäre
sicherlich richtig die experten zu
fragen die jetzt im raume stehen für
während um deren themen es geht
die ideologie uns dazu gezählt über die
pneumologie und überall
anderen medizinischen fachrichtungen
aber das ist das eine das virus und
damit umzugehen die risiken eingeschätzt
habe der anderen seite ist das
ökonomische das was wir an belastungen
in die ökonomie reinbringen als eben
angedeutet auch mit dramatischen
möglicherweise gesundheits und
psychosozialen folgen verbund deswegen
ist es kein gegeneinander wir müssen
jetzt schritte definieren
in der vorne weise ist es den iren ein
spieler der sehr klug ein jahr von den
menschen gesagt worden was sie auch
erleben der einzelhandel im
lebensmittelbereich ist ja sehr gut
damit umgegangen diese erfahrung können
wir relativ einfach auch viele andere
einzelhändler auch auf die gastronomie
übertragen
denn das sind alles geschäft die wir
ansonsten vor die wand fahren sehen
künftig unsere innenstädte anders aus
das sind existenzen dramatisch bedroht
hier kam der abstandsregel über hygiene
regeln über bestimmte
sicherheitsmaßnahmen die dinge einfach
definieren wer das kann kann da noch
widerstehen
also es wirtschaftlicher sicht ganz klar
wer sollte als erstes jetzt wieder
aufmachen dürfen wo wir die erfahrung
haben dass es geht dass wir das risiko
dann auch dpd einheben können das ist
wie eben genannt der einzelhandel ist
auch die gastronomie werkstatt regeln
halten einheiten können ich glaube auch
ganz wichtig ist die völlige in gang
setzen der öffentlichen verwaltung
jahren gebührt glaubst das ist machbar
da kann man auch in den
verwaltungsgebäuden entsprechende
vorsorge sicherstellen
und natürlich ist da die frage schulen
und kindertagesstätten ausdauer nicht
wichtig denn da geht es ja nicht nur um
die frage können die eltern zur arbeit
sondern dies mit bildungsgerechtigkeit
denn dass kinder zu hause sind heißt das
sie auch ungleiche chancen haben in dem
künftigen jahr das darf nicht lange
dauern
deswegen muss man kluge entscheidung zu
finden ich finde man kann über andere
zeitstrukturen den schulen nach den
schichtbetrieb vielleicht mal bestimmten
tagen andere kombinationen von
präsenzunterricht und digital gestützt
im unterricht und wir müssen hier wieder
vor allen dingen auch mit blick auf
bildungsgerechtigkeit erkennbare
schritte in den nächsten wochen geben
herthas mal an sie die frage wenn es um
schulen geht was ist dort aus
gesundheitlicher sicht das beste das man
erst die jüngeren wieder kommen lässt
die älteren können alle gleich wieder
zur schule was wäre da wahrscheinlich
der richtige weg
kinder mit natürlicher der eltern wenn
es nach der psychiater gehen müsste man
so schnell wie die kinder die schule
wieder aufmachen
also es ist so dass wir jetzt natürlich
sagen müssen die kinder sind eher
widerstandsfähiger gegen den virus dann
muss man auch gucken welche gruppen dort
aus genommen haben soll
da bin ich der meinung ist ziel richtig
zielgerichtet wenn wir zuerst die
abschlussklassen nehmen vom grundschüler
auch weiter für den schulhof des
gymnasiums und dann kann man sehen wir
haben eine bestimmte gruppe wir sehen
wie sich das entwickelt wenn wir da
öffnen
das zweite ist wir müssen uns genau
kontrollieren weil jugendliche eben
einfach die tendenz sei aufgrund ihrer
entwicklung oder auch nicht entwicklung
ist ja als sehr leichtfertig teilweise
mit gespannten gehen deswegen müssen wir
das auch gut beobachten schon
kontrollieren und sehen wie sieht es
ausgeht es nur leicht oder stark hoch
und je nachdem können wir sagen der
geben schritt weiter und da bin ich ganz
bayern mütter da müssen wir langsam aber
sicher nach vorne kommen was wir aber
nicht machen und was meiner meinung
macht irgendwelche sachen machen einfach
weil es jetzt angesagt ist oder weil es
bequemer ist weil wir müssen einfach
aufpassen des britischen trinkgeld und
sauber machen und den leuten erklären
wie verstehen dass die sind nämlich
nicht dumm die zehn nach mit sie haben
ja auch gemerkt das ist keine
massenschlägerei gekommen sondern eher
weniger die leute an mitgezogen
wir müssen sie mit nimmt das ist ganz
ganz wichtig eine letzte frage an sie
beide was erwarten oder wünschen sich
morgen von der regierung vor allem von
angela merkel vielleicht herr hüther sie
als erstes das klar erkennbar wird wie
wir in diese normalisierung hinein kommt
dass das ein längerer fahrt ist es
glaube ich allen klar mittlerweile es
muss schrittweise sein wir müssen dabei
auch stückweise lernen ist es auch eben
angedeutet worden
aber es kann nicht sein dass wir diese
debatte unterdrücken sondern wir
brauchen jetzt klarheit menschen müssen
sich darauf einstellen und noch einmal
es ist kein gegeneinander von wirtschaft
und gesundheit in die grad dramatischen
folgen einer depression einer
wirtschaftlichen depression für die
menschen ist auch gesundheitlich
vielfachen studien belegt deswegen
müssen wir jetzt diesen weg führen dass
erst stabilisiert erwartungen dann
können sich menschen darauf einstellen
das heißt aber auch in die kriterien
definieren
dass sie sich entsprechend auch in ihren
kräften beispielsweise aber auch in
produktionsbetrieben auf sicherheit
hygiene standards einlassen können das
ist ja auch in den letzten wochen schon
geübt und das ist ja recht auch von
ihnen angesprochen worden
wir haben ja eigentlich gute erfahrung
gemacht es ist nicht so schlägerei
gekommen
diese gesellschaft ist eine durchaus
erwachsene bündige und das gilt auch
jetzt in dem weg heraus aus dieser
schweren zeit dass mal was erwarten sie
morgen franke der merkel und der
regierung
ich hoffe haben mir dass wir uns auf
einen weg gegeben einen logischen und
durch daten weg wir heben wir die
quarantäne langsam auf aber dass das er
seit anfang eines prozesses ist nämlich
der prozess sollte lauten wie gehen wir
weiter mit unserer gesundheit
wie gehen wir weiter mit risikoanalysen
um was es uns die gesundheit wert und
wie gehen wir einfach mit den
gesundheitsrisiken wie es einfach gilt
weiter
natur ist nämlich nicht nur schön den
erwartungsgemäß mittelfinger gezeigt und
wie sieht das aus wenn wir im nächsten
oder übernächsten jahr wieder so etwas
bekommen also ganz wichtig es muss ein
anfang eines prozesses seien ja wie
gehen wir mit gesundheit umgehen wollen
wir unsere gesellschaft das ist es uns
wert das ist die entscheidende sache
nicht immer nur feuerwehr sondern lass
uns doch mal ein bisschen voraus war
wo stehen wir in drei oder vier jahren